Hi! Welcome to Part 2 of the W3C HTML5 course. How about we start by looking at advanced
HTML5 multimedia features? First, we will look at the Web Audio API that helps processing
and synthesizing audio in Web applications. You will be able to load sound samples into memory
and play them, loop them, process them through a chain of sound effects such as reverberation,
delay, graphic equalizer, compressor, distortion, etc. You can also write nice real time visualizations
like dancing frequency graphs, animated waveforms that dance with the music,
or generate music programmatically.
The Web Audio API is particulary suited for games or for music applications.
A second nice multimedia feature is the Track API.
With it, you will be able to synchronize a video with elements in your document.
For example: display a Google Map, an HTML description
or a Wikipedia page aside the video, while it’s playing.
As always, do not hesitate to practice coding looking at the interactive examples, and then
please share your own creations in the discussion forum!
We hope you will enjoy this first week and we wish you the best!